وصل مدير الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
وليامبيونز الى اسرائيل في زياره تتضمن
محادثات مع قاده اسرائيليين قبل الانتقال
الى رام الله لملاقات قيادات سياسيه
وامنيه فلسطينيه وتكتسي الزياره التي
تتوسط زياره مستشار الامن القومي
جيكسوليفان ووزير الخارجيه
خاصه في ظل التصعيد العسكري الاسرائيلي في
الضفه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مصارعه ما الذي تحمله
الزيارات المتتاليه لمسؤولين امريكيين
بارزين من افكار وتاثيرات المحتمله بشان
الاوضاع الامنيه المتصاعده في الضفه واي
اوراق تملكها الولايات المتحده لفرد
التهدئه كيف تتفاعل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بتشكيلاتها وممارستها الحاليه مع التحركات
الامريكيه وما يمكن ان تتضمنه من مبادره
لخفض التوتر بالنظر الى تاريخ العلاقه بين
المياه واداره بايدي والى اين تسير
الاوضاع الراهنه في ظل دخول جبهه غزه على
خط الصعيد والخيارات الممكنه فلسطينيه وما
قد يرشحوا عن جلسه مجلس الامن بما تحكمه
من موازينه تؤثر المواقف الدوليه
والاقليميه من الملف الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
هي بحسب موقع زياره المقررات سلفا لكن
تصعيد العسكريه الاسرائيلي الجاري في
الضفه وفي قطاع غزه يطفي عليها ابعد هامه
انها تلك التي يقوم بها مدير المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز الى تل ابيب
ثم رام الله ايام قليله بعد زياره مستشار
الامن القومي وقبل اخرى مرتبه لوزير
الخارجيه
القيادات الاسرائيليه والفلسطينيه اعقبت
زياره قام بها الى مصر موقع ولا
الاسرائيليين نقل عن مصدرين امريكيين
تتنزل ضمن جهد امريكي دبلوماسيه اوسع يشمل
زياره المرتقبه الى المنطقه واضاف الموقع
في تقريره انه من المنتظر ان يلعب برنسيا
في العمل على تهدئه الاوضاع
وفي نيويورك يعقدوا مجلس الامن الدولي
جلسه مشاورات مغلقه اليوم بشان الاوضاع في
الشرق الاوسط بما في ذلك القضيه
الفلسطينيه وتتضمر الجلسه احاطه للمنسق
الاممي الخاص لعمليه السلام في الشرق
الاوسط تورنزلاند
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
لحركه المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
لتتمكن من تحقيق هذا الهدف في الوقت الذي
تتصاعد فيه الامور على الارض
اسمعني كويس
على الارض فعلا فظيع جدا
وهو من منطقه ان نجد مثل هذا مثل هذا
التصاعد ونامل انه سيتوقف وان الموقف
الامريكي واعتقدوا الموقف المناسب هو
محاوله تهدئه جميع الاطراف وهذا يشمل
اسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه طبعا وبالتالي
في توقيت هذه الزياره
ثم اسبوع القادم
وزير الخارج
في المنطقه
هي التطوير العلاقات وما هي رؤيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده حول التواصل مع
الفلسطينيين وكيف انه سيتعاملون مع
المنطقه الان ب- بوجود المسجد الحكومات
اليمنيه متطرفه وكذ قضايا اخرى تتعلق
باسرائيل وعلاقاتها مع روسيا في حرب
اوكرانيا هناك امور كثيره تجري مناقشتها
ولكن بالتاكيد العنف سيكون هو على راس
نقطه المناقشات للوزير الخارجيه في
الاسبوع القادم دكتور مصطفى اذا جايك
سوليفان ثم ويليامبرز وبعد ذلك سيكون هناك
زياره لالينكن ما الذي يمكن الولايات
المتحده ان تفعله في هذه الزياره
المتتاليه
لا يمكن ان تفعل شيء كثير ما لم تغير
جذريا موقفها
وتغيير موقفها جذريا يعني التوقف عن ان
تكون منحاذه بشكل كامل لاسرائيل وانت
تتوقف عن استعمال مصطلحات وتعبير همم تسمم
الفلسطينيين والنظارهم الوطني بالارهاب
وان تقبل بان تفرض ضغوط وعقوبات على
اسرائيل وتهديد اسرائيل بالعقوبات حتى
تتوقع عن الاجرام الذي يمارس ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني
المصطلحات نفسها غريبه يعني عندما يقول
ضيفك العنف ماذا يعني العنف ومن يمارس
العنف من الذي قتل منذ بدايه هذا الشهر 30
فلسطينيا حتى اليوم اليس جيش الاحتلال من
الذي قتل في العام الماضي 224 فلسطين
فلسطيني من الذي يحتل ارض الفلسطينيين من
يمارس نظام الابارتيد العنصري حسب تقارير
كل مؤسسات الامم المتحده ومؤسسات حقوق
الانسان المعروفه في العالم لا يمكن
المساواه بين طرفين وبعد ذلك توقع ان
تستطيع الولايات المتحده ان تلعب دورا
ايجابيا انا برايي همم سيجامل
الاسرائيليين الاسرائيليين سيجامل ربما
الوفود الامريكيه
ببعض التهدئه ولكن ما ان يغادر سيبدا
بعمليات الاجرام كما حدث اثناء زياره
بنيامين نتنياهو للاردن ماء عاد حتى بدا
الاجرام وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه لا تستطيع
الولايات المتحده فعلا ان تكون مؤثرا ان
لم تغير جذريا موقفها بالتوقفها عن
الانحياز لاسرائيل وبالتخاد موقف صارم
تجاه حقيقه ان الذين يحكمون في اسرائيل
اليوم مش بس متطرفون عنصريون وانما فاشون
ايضا طيب
يمكن من خلالها ان يعمل على همم
التهدئه ان جاء ليجامل الاسرائيليين كما
يقول الدكتور مصطفى
وائل
انها زياره مجامله
الوزير بيرزان اساميه والزيري لكن
المسؤول المخابرات يعرف المنطقه افضل من
اي شخص اخر فقد كان السفيرنا في الاردن
وايضا كان السفيرنا في موسكو وبالتالي هو
لديهم كثير
تهتم كثيرا بما يصدر من كلام عن حكومه وما
يسبب من ذلك من نوع ما
يزيد التوتر الموجود وبالتالي فان المدير
همم سوف يطرح بعض الحقائق ويقطعها على
اسرائيل بشكل واضح هذه الزياره الواقع
مقدمه اجتماعاتهم مع الوزير الذي
في وزاره الخارجيه واعتقدنا الوزير
وحتى السيارات الاخرى الكونغرس وعدم
الاستقرار مع الفلسطينيين وبين استقرار
وفلسطين واسرائيل ايضا يمكن ان ينفجر في
اي لحظه وفي الصواريخ التنطلق من من غزه
والان اسرائيل بدات منذ قصف غزه
النحو والسلام والحوار كلما زاد الخطر
وخاصه بهذه الحكومه الاسرائيلي حاليا التي
لا لم تظهر اي اهتمام ورغبه في دعم طموحات
الفلسطينيين كما ناقشنا ذلك هنا من سنوات
عديده الدكتور مصطفى في المقابل في رايك
ما الذي يمكن ان يطرحه وليامبرز على
الجانب الفلسطيني وما الذي يمكن ان تجيب
به القياده الفلسطينيه
ربما يكون بانت فعلا من اكثر ناس اطلاعا
وهو زار الاراضي الفلسطينيه عندما كان
هناك اجتياح اسرائيلي في عام 2002 وكان
مساعدا لوزير الخارجيه ويعرف بالتفصيل
ماذا يفعل الاسرائيليون ولكن هل هذا سيعني
ان الموقف الامريكي الذي سيطرح سيكون
مؤثرا انا لا اظن ذلك
ساطرح يعني لنكون محددين ودقيقين يعني مش
مش نتكلم بالعموموميات الاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه قالت انها ستفتح القنصليه
الامريكيه في القدس هل فتحتها لم تفتحها
ادعت في على مدار عام ماضي انها لا تستطيع
ان تفعل ذلك حتى لا يقوى ان نتنياهو ياتي
للحكم طيب جاء الى الحكم الان لماذا لا
تفتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس مثلا
قالت انها ستقوم باجراءات لردع التوسع
الاستيطان الاسرائيلي لماذا فعلت لا شيء
اليوم هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه تقول على
رؤوس الاشهاد انها تريد ضم الضفه الغربيه
ترفض حل الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله ترفض
ما سمي بحل الدولتين
وترفض حتى مجرد الجلوس والتفاوض مع اي حدا
مع اي فلسطين وبالتالي ماذا تفعل الاداره
الامريكيه بهذا الشان انا اخشى ان كل
الضغط الان سيكون موجه على السلطه
الفلسطينيه كي تعيد التنسيق الامني الذي
قررت ان توقفه بعد بسبب الغضب الشعبي
والشعب الفلسطيني يريد ليس فقط ان ينتهي
التنسيق الامن بل ان تسقط كل هذه
الاتفاقيات التي مزقتها اسرائيل وعن همم
ينهى التنسيق الامني الى الابد لانه كل
عقيده التنسيق الامني مع الاحتلال العقيده
خاطئه انا اخشى ان الضغط سيسير في الاتجاه
المعاكس على جانب الفلسطيني السؤال
الرئيسي اذا كانت الولايات المتحده لماذا
لا تقوم باجراءات ملموسه محدده ولماذا
تواصل محاوله ارضاء الاسرائيليين ولماذا
تتبنى موقفا منحازا هذا هو جوهر المشكله
القضيه الاكبر الان ما هي سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وماذا تفعل الولايات المتحده
اذا ذلك عندما يكون بينج فير واسميترتش
الفاشين المصنفين سابقا كارهابيين حتى في
الولايات المتحده عندما يكونوا هم مسؤولين
عن الامن ومسؤولين عن كل ما يجري
الفلسطينيين ويعلن ليل نهار انهم ينهون
تدمير الوضع في المسجد الاقصى ينون توزيع
المستعمرات الاستيطانيه ينون ضم الضفه
الغربيه هل سمعنا عن تهديد امريكي بعقوبات
ضد اسرائيل لماذا ازدواجيه المعايير تستمر
لماذا 10,000 عقوبه في حاله روسيا ولا
عقوبه واحده في حاله اسرائيل هذا هو
السؤال الرئيس همم حسنا يعني في جديد
التصريحات والمواقف الصادره بشان التصعيد
العسكري الاسرائيلي في الضفه والقطاع ووسط
التساؤلات عن تفاصيل خطته في التعامل مع
الوضع الراهن خلال البيت الابيض انه قلق
اذا اتجدد العنف في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وانه يدين الافعال التي تؤدي الى تص
التوتر واضاف البيت الابيض ان الحاجه ملحه
لخفض العنف من قبل جميع الاطراف في
اسرائيل والاراضي الفلسطينيه جر بالنار
لعلك استمعت همم الى الى الاسئله الكثيره
التي ترحها الدكتور مصطفى وجزها في
النهايه بسؤال واحد لماذا لا تتخذ
الولايات المتحده اجراءات حقيقيه وما وعدت
به لم تنفذ اي منهم من جمله الاشياء التي
سندها وبالتالي هو يقول وكثيرون يرون ان
الضغط في الحقيقه سوف يكون على الجانب
الفلسطيني اللي اعاده التنسيق الامني ولم
يكون هناك اي ضغط على اسرائيل في همم كايل
بمكيالين واضح تمارسه الولايات المتحده
منذ عقود وليس الان فقط
هناك عده امور هنا اولا وقبل كل شيء ان
العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه قويه
علاقات شراكه ثنائيه وتحالف وهي صداقه
وهذا وهي علاقه عميقه هناك سبب ذلك انها
تعود الى عقود من الماضي وهذا للتغير في
امريكا واذا ما يتعلق بالشعب الفلسطيني
ليس من مصلحه الفلسطينيه
في الضفه الغربيه من مصلحه فلسطينيه تهدئه
الامور لا اعتقد ان قوات الامن همم تود ان
تقوم به هجمات ضد مقاتله همم
ولكن ما قالوا سيد بالروثي صحيح همم لا بد
ان يكون هناك نوع من التحرك او التصرف
تقوم به الولايات المتحده لتشجيع المزيد
من الحوار نحو تحقيق السلامه وقد شاهدنا
قبل سنوات عندما
عن ضم الاراضي شاهدنا الدول العربيه مالت
وضع الضغوطا عليه ايضا يشاهدنا اداره
فايدل مده يديها لهذه الدول وقالت لهم
دعونا نجد طريقه لاشتراك الفلسطينيين في
هذه المناقشات مثلا في طارفه اتفاقات رهام
والنقد
لابد من القيام به مزيد من الجهود المتحده
تنظر الى الوضع اما موجود في السياسات
وهو افضل نتيجه همم
الوصول الى السلام او هذا هو السبب هذه
الزياره
هذه تفهم انها حكومه غير ملتزمه حاليا
بهذه النتيجه هو هذا ليس وهذا وهذا ليس
جيد للامريكا ولا في فلسطين اسرائيليين
وامن ان هذه الزيارات ستنقل هذه الرساله
وتوصلها
ولكن لابد من القيام بالمزيد من الاجراءات
والتحركات لتهدئه الوضع بدلا من
تسمح للنيران ان تنفجر كما حصل في هذا
الاسبوع اذا لا شخص يستفيد من ذلك ضيفنا
دكتور مصطفى من واشنطن يتفق معك ويعتقد
انه لابد من عمل المزيد هل تعتقد انه قد
يقرا اي همم اي اي تغيير على الدور
الامريكي
وديناميته
مع وصفه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بي همم
الدبلوماسيه واسعه تقوم بها ادارهته في
الوقت الحالي
للاسف انا يعني اتمنى لو انه هذا غير صحيح
ولكن هذا غير صحيح لن يحدث
وهو يتفق معي شكرا ولكن انا لا اتفق مع
المصطلحات التي يستعملها مثلا عندما
تستعمل مصطلح كالعنف ماذا يعني العنف يعني
المساواه بين الطرفين لماذا في بلدان اخرى
يحق للذي تحت الاحتلال ان يقاوم الاحتلال
ولكن هذا محرم على الفلسطينيين ولماذا
مقاومه الفلسطينيين تسمى عنفا وتواضع مع
القمع الاسرائيلي الذي يمارس ضدهنه
الاداره الامريكيه الشيء الوحيد الذي وضع
الثقالها في اتجاهه هو استمرار في مقام به
ترامب معنى ياهو بمحاوله فرط تطبيع مع
المحيط العربي على حساب القضيه الفلسطينيه
ونحن نعرف ان التطبيعه او ما يسمى
باتفاقات هي كانت وسيله لجذب الانظار عن
القضيه الفلسطينيه ولتهمشها تمهيدا
لتصفياتها واليوم البرنامج المعلن للحكومه
الاسرائيليه هو التصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه
وضم الضفه الغ فكره حل الدولتين التي
يتحدثون عنها ينبمثابه قفص يريد ان يضعوا
الفلسطينيين في هذا القفص ويظلوا يحكوا عن
حل الدولتين واسرائيل اعدم اتحل الدوله
وقتلت حل الدوله ونسفت حل الدولتين لم
يبقى شيء منه ومع ذلك يريد ان الفلسطينيين
ان يجلسوا ولا يفعلوا شيء لذلك انا اخشى
ان الجهود الامريكيه في الاساس موجهه نحو
تهدئه الفلسطينيين بحيث لا يقاوم الظلم
الذي يعيشونه وبحيث يتوقفوا عن مقاومه
الاحتلال ويتوقفوا عن مقاومه النظام
الافرنت هذه العنصري حتى تنهي اسرائيل هذا
المشروع الذي نهايته تطهير عرقي
للفلسطينيين ونهايه تضم للضفه الغربيه
لذلك طبعا اذا كان هذا الهدف هذا لن ينجح
ولن يمر لانه الشعب الفلسطيني اليوم ادرك
اولا انه ليس لا يجب ان ينتظر مساعده من
الخارج عليه ان يعتمد على نفسه عليه ان
ينظم نفسه انا كنت اليوم في جنين في مخيم
جنين وزورت عائلات الشه وزاره عائله
الشهداء في مدينه جنين ما ما هو ذنب امراه
عمرها 61 سنه كانت تقف في داخل منزلها
واطلق الرصاص عليها وقتلها هل عقب جندي
اسرائيلي واحد على ذلك هل جرى تحقيق وعقاب
لمن قام بقتل شيرين ابو عقله هل قامت
الاداره الامريكيه بتهديد اسرائيل بعقوبات
ان لم تعاقب من قابه بقتل شيرين ابو عقله
طبعا لا شيء ولذلك جذر المشكله جوهر
المشكله ان الاساس الذي تقوم عليه السياسه
الامريكيه هي سياسه من هذا الاسرائيلي
للاسف على اسرائيل وهذا يجب ان يتغير اجر
روبن وهناك جلسه لمجلس الامن اليوم الذي
يمكن ان نتوقع منه يعني وهل يمكن الولايات
المتحده ان تدين ما يفعله
الاسرائيليون كما تدين ما يفعلها الروس في
اوكرانيا ويفعله معتدون اخرون في اماكن
اخرى ام لن يكون هناك مؤشر اي مؤشر على اي
تغيير واي اجابه
على اسئله الدكتور مصطفى
ان هذا انا نزاع او حرب مختلفه عما يحصل
فيه روسيا واوكرانيا لكنه واضحين روسيا
غزت من جانب واحد اوكراني قبل حوالي سنه
وهذه حرب مستمره منذ عقود او نزاع مستمر
وزير العقود وهو نزاع الفضيع بدون شكلات
لكن المقارنه بينهما ليس لا يمكن علينا
وفقا للقانون الدولي وليس في رايي الشخصي
هذه ارض محتله والاسرائيليون قوه محتله
وليس هناك يعني اي شخص همم يعترض على هذا
على هذه الحقيقه في واقع العمل
الاختلاف هو انه عندما نتحدث عن الاحتلال
الان بين اسرائيل وفلسطين مين هذا امر
نساء عقود من الزمن وفيه عمليات صاحبه
وعمليات دبلوماسيه تطور تقدمته فقط وهكذا
اما غزوه روسيا لاخرانيه عسكريه ليس هناك
اي عمليه دبلوماسيه حاليا وروسيا تقوم
بغسل طويل المدى وهجوم المستمر وبالتالي
الامر مختلف هذا لا يعني ليس كلاهما سيئه
فيما يحصل ولكنهم مختلفون
متطابقه كلا بهذه المنطقه يعني
الولايات المتحده لا بد تدافع عن كل
ديمقراطيه في العالم دون التوقف هذا اننا
ندخل الى نقاشا لا نهايه له نهايه اسرائيل
هذا مهم
نتالق الامر بمجلس الامن والامم المتحده
وقرارات الامم المتحده لتعود لعقود حول
هذا النساء اليوم انا متاكد بان سنسمع همم
القلق تعبر عن الولايات المتحده
والدعوه الى تهدئه الطرفين ونسمع الدعوات
الانسحاب من اجراءات
الاستفزازات
الدكتور مصطفى للتعليق ما هي خيارات
الفلسطينيين في دقيقه اذا كان ممكنا
خيارنا الاعتماد على النفس ومقاومه هذا
الاحتلال المجرم وتوحيد الصف الوطني
والاستمرار في اجراءات وقف التنسيق
بالكامل مع الجانب الاسرائيلي ولكن دعني
اوضح ما هو الفرق بين الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وغيره الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ليس فقط احتلال
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قام على قاعده تطهير
عرقي هو الاسوا في القرن ال 21
الاحتلال الان اصبح نظام عنصري اسوا من ما
كان في جنوب افريقيا الاحتلال يمارس مجازر
ضد الشعب الذي يقع تحت هلاله وفي ذلك لا
يمكن حتى ان يساوي مع اي وضع في اي مكان
في العالم هذا اسواضع يمكن ان يكون وهذا
ما اقر به حتى اصدقاءنا في جنوب افريقيا
يقولون الابر تايد الموجود عندكم اسوء حتى
لما كان في جنوب افريقيا وهذا سبب اضافي
لكي تكون الولايات المتحده وكل الدول
الغربيه في موقف مختلفه وان تفرض عقوبات
على اسرائيل اذا اردت ان تكون مؤثره اخرى
شكرا جزيلا من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام لحركه المبادره
وطنيه الفلسطينيه 28
روب النائب المساعد الاسبق لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي شكرا جزيلا لكم احمد
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]